Ukraine says it is bracing for a new
push from Russian forces in the Eastern
region of donbath and in the South
President Vladimir zelenski said Moscow
could not admit that its operation was
quote at a dead end now his comments
come as Russian forces started
withdrawing from the second largest city
of khiv following a Ukrainian
counter-offensive but while the threat
may be receding from hahib for civilians
still left in the city conditions a dire
for the thousands of people still
Sheltering in hakeem's Metro System the
war is far from over
after weeks of shelling that's left much
of the city in Ruins some are scared to
leave the safety of the Underground
we're very afraid to go home there are
so many explosions so many bombs were
very afraid it's a lot of pressure
others say that the worst seems to be
behind them
at the beginning it was extremely hard
because there were a lot of people here
and a lot of Destruction we all felt
defeated now we haven't heard bombs for
the last three to four days
that's likely to be down to the
Ukrainian counter-offensive that seen
soldiers retake nearby Villages like
this one north of hark Eve
with Ukraine claiming on Sunday that
some of its troops had even reached the
border with Russia and set up a new
border post
foreign
gains in the region come as as it
started putting Western supplied heavy
weapons into action
Ukraine's Army says this is one of
several recently arrived U.S howitzers
it's already using on the front line in
the east
with Russia still trying to advance in
the donbaths they're certain to see even
more action in the days to come
and we can cross straight to DW
correspondent I mean Asif now he's in
leviv in Western Ukraine I mean the
Ukrainian military says Russian units
have suffered significant losses as they
try to advance through the luhansk and
Donetsk regions what more can you can
you tell us about that
the Ukrainian military has called this a
devastating setback for Russia and it's
backed up by British intelligence that
Russia has lost up to one-third of its
military forces in the east of Ukraine
this is over 10 000 soldiers uh also
hundreds of artillery pieces and dozen
are over a dozen ships now what we are
seeing on the ground as we've heard is
that har Keef has essentially been
liberated from attacks by Russia it
never fell to Russian forces but it was
under attack and this is you can't
underestimate how much this means for
ukrainians harkiv is the second largest
city in Ukraine it was one of three
major cities including uh Kiev the
capital and mariupole in the South that
came under instant attack by Russians
after the invasion and now Kiev as well
as harkiv have been liberated from
attacks by Rush questions but Harkey
remember is not exactly in the
donbassads bordering the region and in
the donbass Russia has secured a lot of
areas it's bombarding 23 cities uh 23
towns and cities right now and um U.S
intelligence kind of contradicts what
we're hearing from British intelligence
and ukrainians and what they're saying
is that it's become a stalemate in the
Don Bassin that we're likely to see a
prolonged conflict there
Russian forces fired at a hospital in
severo Donetsk on Sunday can you give us
some more details about what happened
there
Ukraine said that nine civilians were
wounded in that attack on a hospital
severo Donetsk is in within range of
Russian Artillery so it really puts a
strain on the city Russia has almost
completely surrounded there have been
some gains by ukrainians including the
bombing of a temporary bridge over a
river outside of that city which was a
major setback for Russia and they lost a
lot of troops but Russia is really
focusing on severo donets that's because
it's the easternmost City still under
the control of Ukrainian troops and if
Russia was able to claim that City it
would have de facto control of all the
donbass which is a region which Russia
has used to justify its invasion of
Ukraine saying that it wanted to
liberate the East and protect the
russian-speaking population there from
attacks by ukrainians
CW's I mean Asif in Lev thanks so much
now at a meeting of NATO foreign
ministers in Berlin Secretary General
Jen stotenberg delivered an upbeat
assessment of Ukraine's battle against
invading Russian forces here's some of
what he had to say
Ukraine can win this war
ukrainians are bravely defending their
Homeland
Russia's war in Ukraine is not going as
Moscow had planned
they failed to take years
they're pulling back from around concave
their major offensive in donbos has
stalled
Russia is not achieving its strategic
objectives
Frank ludwige is our regular military
analyst and he joins me now from Oxford
in the UK welcome Frank we just heard
there NATO Secretary General saying
Russia's war is not going to plan and
that Ukraine could win this conflict
would you agree with him
and you know to put it mildly the war
isn't going to plan as to whether
Ukraine can win that is contingent on
whether the West continues to supply
Ukraine at the same or an increased rate
the Americans are right in fact so the
British they're not necessarily
inconsistent what's developing in the
south east now around the town of Severa
Donetsk and lishansk is a a battle of a
battle of attrition and that's not going
to be easy at all it's going to take
several months and unless Ukraine
continues to receive the Munitions they
need such as those artillery pieces you
saw in the piece then they will that
they they don't face defeat but they
won't be able to win one can't emphasize
enough they need those weapons to
continue coming in greater and greater
quantities
can we talk about the reports we're
hearing that Russian forces may have
fired phosphorus bombs at the as of
style steel plant over the weekend do
you think it was phosphorus that was
used and if so what does this tell us
about Russia's military strategy going
forward
yes Anya it looked to me looking at
those horrendous pictures that that was
phosphorus those are phosphorus bombs
phosphorus is illegal it's unlawful
under the Hague conventions or the Hague
series of conventions in the law of arm
conflict because it's incentury it burns
and burns and cannot be put out an
incendiary weapon it's an unlawful
weapon and it demonstrates a certain
level of Last Resort from Russia you are
escalating up the ladder of of unlawful
Weaponry where she was fully aware of
that and it does say something however
what we must remember is that my Apple
still stands it's likely to remain in
Ukrainian hands for quite some time this
is a heroic and historic military
defensive action on the part of the
Defenders so yes Russian desperation but
yes also Ukraine continues to hang on
there the British defense Ministry we're
hearing is saying that Belarus has
announced the deployment of Special
Operation uh forces along the Ukrainian
border how significant is this would you
say
it's nothing new the Bella Russians just
finished their uh spring exercises so
their forces are mobilized along that
southern front anyway and have been for
several weeks that in itself is not
significant there is no way I think and
most analysts would agree that Belarus
is going to take part in this war
actively with its main force in sort of
main main core of soldiers and armor
what they're doing however is fixing
Ukrainian forces in place and
particularly with with mentions as you
said before they're special forces
that's going to require countermeasures
on the part of ukrainians and that means
that those forces will not be
reinforcing donbass so what they're
doing is holding Ukrainian defenses in
place up there there's no way really
that Belarus politically can can get
involved actively lukashenko president
of Belarus he needs those forces in his
country to make sure that his own rather
shaky regime stays in place so we
shouldn't worry about Invasion from
there but yes they're significant in the
war in that they're holding Ukrainian
forces in place up there around Kiev
military analyst Frank ledwich thanks as
ever
thank you Anya
now in other developments in the Ukraine
conflict Ukraine has accused Russia of
dropping phosphorus bombs on the as of
style steel plant in Mario Paul images
of the alleged attack were released by a
pro-russian separatist Commander the
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
says negotiations on saving Ukrainian
troops defending the as of style plant
are at a complicated and delicate phase
Ukrainian sources say some 1 000 people
are holding out at the site more than 80
days after the invasion started they're
refusing to surrender to Russian forces